[Music]
you've done a couple of action movies
since the last time I saw your book of
UI Max Payne and I've noticed it's like
you're so funny but you seems like you
have the ability to tap into being a
badass you do you like being in those
kinds of movies do you like action
movies I do I mean I like being in them
I'm really far from a badass like I'm
not like you know awesome at anything so
can you can you fight yes I can fake it
I did really Stern looks and I feel like
that's that sells it that's all you need
really and really in real life you are
someone who can give someone a look and
that just takes it yeah totally like
that's you know it just it gets the job
done
okay it scares them enough - all right
let me try something right now let's
just say I walked up to I didn't know
you that well and I just said oh you
excuse me you just look like someone
who'd owned a lot of cats that is pretty
good
I get that but you know what that's how
Annie looks at me during the monologue
[Laughter]
every night I'm out there telling jokes
and then we cut to Andy and Jess can you
fight it all you see you don't really
fight no no I mean well no you can't
even give an elbow I think I can like no
stop it and like guess what Neela I can
do that too whenever stuff whenever
stuff really starts to go down I'm
really good at like taking off my coat
and approaching a gang and just being
like stop it then later at the hospital
no I can't do I did I'm Max Payne oddly
enough there was like a big snowstorm
and so the production shut down Wow yeah
so I had a lot of practice with Gump's
and I was given like free range so I
learned how to take apart put together
gone I'm actually pretty good at a gun
I can shoot pretty well an automatic and
a semi-automatic and I learned how to
keep my eyes open while shooting a gun
which sounds crazy but it's really hard
to do it's hard to do if you actually
want to flinch yeah that's one of the
biggest problems for people especially
in films when they're firing if I was
ever an action star which is gonna
happen if I ever had a fire machine gun
just be
you know the whole time and they put it
in slow motion now because the slow-mo
and digitally they'd have to go back and
give me open eyes but they'd be really
fake open eyes I thought I've told this
before but I had to shoot a gun in a
movie in a scene and the first two takes
as I shot the gun which actually had you
know live rounds in it I went do you
know you're going let me ask you about
Ted Ted I got to see this a couple
nights ago and it's a really funny movie
and it's a great idea you shot this film
in Boston I'm from Boston were you so I
mean so you shot the movie there you
have to spend a lot of time there did it
surprise you it's kind of a tough town
in some respects yeah it's a great town
like before 7 p.m.
like after 7 p.m. just going doors right
you know people there get crazy very not
they like to drink and they're not
afraid to tell you what they think or
show you physically what they think
cuz that ass I mean literally that town
it's um it's a fun town don't get me
wrong but boy people there love their
beer like they just beer out hop
everywhere it's crazy right and there's
a big thing I don't know if you you hung
out with obviously with Mark Wahlberg
yeah and his friends he's known for
having his Boston pals hang out with him
while he's in town and they can get a
little rowdy oh yeah
amongst each other all the time what are
you doing just hitting each over their
head I mean without you know going to
seumas detail and getting into too much
trouble but there are people break into
fights like in the middle of the
afternoon which is crazy to me like it's
2 o'clock you guys take a nap it's fine
but they are like in a brawl in the
middle of the day that's what I see
every time I go back to Boston I'll just
land and I'll be in Logan Airport and I
walk through the terminal and people are
just hitting each other in the head
know what's really good there is there
lobster rolls I mean I'm sure you know
this because you're from that today's
gonna who really yeah right Robster
rolls in Boston are amazing and it's how
they break up most the fights people are
hitting each other and then they lower
one on a string and everyone's like pull
everybody's just calms down